as the founder of Playboy magazine Hugh
Hefner was one of the icons of the
sexual revolution in the 1960s opinions
about Hefner are very polarized you
either love and admire the man or you
completely disapprove of the
multimillion-dollar Empire that he
created but no matter how you feel about
Hugh Hefner there is no arguing that he
was truly a genius when it came to
business and a one-of-a-kind publisher a
writer and entrepreneur
[Music]
Hugh Marsden Hefner was born in Chicago
in 1926 he grew up in the middle of
prohibition and his parents were
conservative Methodists his mother was a
teacher and his father was an accountant
during the Great Depression his father
was under a lot of pressure to work as
hard as he possibly could in order to
keep his job he would leave the house
before Hugh and his brother Keith even
woke up for school and he works late
into the night he was a very timid and a
shy little boy he preferred to read
comic books and watch movies most of the
Hollywood starlets in the 1920s and 30s
just happened to be buxom blonde gals
with an hourglass figure and he grew up
escaping into a fantasy world of romance
and adventure wishing that he could live
inside these movies in elementary school
Hugh did not talk very much and he
didn't seem to be paying attention to
class he spent most of his time drawing
in his notebooks with his mind up in the
clouds he was unresponsive to his
teachers questions as well so they
thought that he might have some sort of
learning disability
his mother took him to a child
psychologist and it turns out that he
had an IQ of a hundred and fifty-two
which makes him a genius the reality was
that he was simply bored with what he
was learning in class when Hugh started
going to high school he had his heart
broken when a girl he had a crush on
started dating another boy this point he
was still shy and had trouble
communicating but the perceived
rejection from this girl was a wake-up
call from that moment on he realized
that he needed to reinvent himself if he
ever wanted to get a girlfriend he asked
his friends to start calling him half
instead of Hugh and he began to wear
nicer clothes cologne and stylist hair
underneath all of these outward
improvements however he was still that
hardcore film that he wrote plays for
the theater department and he films his
own horror movies with a home video
camera with his friends he worked on the
school newspaper and drew comic books in
his spare time when he was fifteen he
created his own zine that he had fully
Illustrated and he called it shudder
here he wrote articles about horror
movies he met up with a group of friends
after school called the
shudder Club where they got together to
watch films and talk about them it was
at this point that he finally came out
of his shell and he was popular enough
to be elected student body president
from 1944 to 1946 Hugh Hefner served in
the US Army
he used his talents in
writing to work for the military's
newspaper since he did not have a combat
position they lived out the adventures
in his mind by drawing comic books about
fantasy missions like one way he and a
group of his friends were breaking
prisoners out of a Nazi concentration
camp during World War two illustrations
and photos of pinup girls were extremely
popular in order to boost soldiers
morale
there were even paintings of Miss
America on the signs of airplane bombers
instead of staring at scantily clad
strangers in his bunk
you have now gazed at photos and letters
from his fiancee mildred williams he was
very much in love with her and they plan
to get married when the war was over
after being discharged from the Army you
have know when to the University of
Illinois and double majored in
psychology and creative writing he
excelled in school and he was able to
earn his bachelor's degree in just two
and a half years he also wrote for the
college newspaper and magazine he was
eager to marry Mildred after graduation
but the idea that he was getting to live
out the plot of a Hollywood romance well
it came crashing down before the wedding
Mildred confessed that she had had an
affair when he was away in the Army he
forgave her though and he lost his
virginity on his wedding night they went
on to have two children together Christy
and David he was very much in love with
Mildred and even though it broke his
heart he believed in the old traditional
way of doing things during an interview
with The New York Times Hefner explained
how he felt on his wedding day the magic
was gone from the very beginning how
would it have turned out without the
affair was I well-suited for marriage I
didn't know but I was truly crushed
[Music]
after serving in the army and graduating
from college Hugh Hefner got a job at a
squire magazine making $60 a week with
modern-day inflation that's about six
hundred and forty five dollars a week
after working there for several years
Hefner knew that he was good at his job
so he asked his boss for a $5 a week
raise this doesn't sound like a lot to
ask but they still said no at this point
he was starting to have a bit of a
quarter life crisis I've been to that
point he had followed all of the rules
of living the so-called American Dream
but he was unhappy with his job and he
was in an unfaithful marriage he decided
that he truly had nothing left to lose
so he quit his job and worked on
starting his own magazine Hugh Hefner
knew from being in the army that men
loved looking at pictures of pin-up
girls when they came home from the war
many men did not have access to it
anymore because it was illegal to send
anything that was considered
pornographic in the mail at that time
men's magazines were mostly about
hunting fishing camping and cars Hefner
saw this as a golden opportunity to
start his own publication the only issue
was that he was completely broke he
borrowed $1,000 from his mother
mortgaged out his furniture to the bank
for $600 and convinced several investors
to help him raise a total of $8,000 to
get the first issue of Playboy started
at first he thought about naming the
magazine stag party that decided against
it since there was already a magazine
called stag Hugh Hefner was able to buy
Marilyn Monroe's nude photos from a
calendar company who earned the rights
these photographs were famous but since
this was decades before people could
easily share photos on the Internet
very few people had actually seen them
for just $200 he bought the rights to
the pictures and published them in the
very first issue of Playboy
since Marilyn Monroe was one of the
biggest celebrities over the time he
couldn't have picked a better woman to
place on the cover magazines were flying
off the shelves and they sold 50,000
copies the money they made from that
issue was just enough to make the second
and after a few months they were turning
a profit soon enough they were selling
over a million copies a month and
playboy was essentially an overnight
success now it sounds like a joke when
people say they read playboy for the
articles but this is actually a lot of
truth to that statement
Hugh Hefner was always against
censorship in the media and he ran one
of the very few publications where
writers could express themselves without
holding back some of the greatest
authors in
world actually got their start writing
for Playboy Ian Fleming was one of them
and he went on to write James Bond's and
Ray Bradbury serialized chapters of
Fahrenheit 451 in the magazine before
publishing the complete novel even
Margaret Atwood published several short
stories in Playboy before writing a
feminist dystopian novel The Handmaid's
Tale in the 1950s Hugh Hefner was
defying all rationale Convention and
actually promoted feminism and women's
sexual liberation as well as racial
equality in 1959 a series called Playboy
his penthouse aired on the television
for the first time women were shown on
TV as more than just housewives who were
staying home to make dinner and take
care of the children
the premise of the show was that the
viewer followed around Hugh Hefner as he
had a classy party in his penthouse
apartment women wore elegant dresses and
men wore suits as they drank cocktails
and had interesting conversations while
they listened to live jazz music it was
sophisticated and that lifestyle became
an aspiration for many men and women who
watched the series now at this point
Hugh Hefner's marriage it was crumbling
and he and his wife Mildred had agreed
to allow one another to sleep with
different people they officially called
it quits in 1959 and got a divorce which
left him free to live the bachelor
lifestyle to match the Playboy brand
that same year he bought his first
mansion and opens the Playboy Club in
Chicago soon enough he would open dozens
of clubs all over the country so that
men could experience the Playboy his
penthouse lifestyle firsthand by the
time he turned 35 the Playboy Empire had
expanded to a lifestyle brand worth 20
million dollars as time went on the
magazine would come to be published in
over 180 countries and it became one of
the top 20 brands in the entire world
right-wing conservatives they were
against Playboy
from the very first issue because they
considered the magazine to be a sinful
trash he also got a lot of criticism
from the left as well because feminists
saw that it was objectifying and over
sexualizing women rather than liberating
them after receiving so much criticism
Hugh Hefner published a book called the
Playboy of philosophy in 1962 where he
explains his ideas about sex in modern
culture and attempts to explain his
thought process behind running for
business in 1963 a journalist named
Gloria Steinem went undercover for show
magazine to work as a waitress in one of
the Playboy Clubs she found out that
these girls were being underpaid and
they were charged fees whenever they
committed even the smallest infractions
like not smiling enough they were also
being treated very badly by the
customers and in the ends women hardly
made any money in order to be sexually
objectified clients were given special
keys that allowed them to have total
access to the Playboy Bunnies which made
the club a glorified brothel Steinem
wrote about her experiences and she was
seen as a hero for feminism by exposing
what was going on behind closed doors
now he hath done he took this criticism
seriously and responded by making sure
that the women working in his clubs they
were being treated fairly and being paid
a proper wage but as they say even bad
press is good press and despite all of
the controversy the playboy brand
continued to thrive
[Music]
today it's difficult to imagine playboy
without the mansion filled with
beautiful girls but Hugh Hefner did not
buy the iconic house in Los Angeles
until 1974 the mansion sits on five
acres and comes with a movie room a
massive wine cellar a gym tennis courts
and even a zoo with exotic animals
you haven't began hosting some of the
biggest parties in history at the
Playboy Mansion with celebrity guests
visiting on a regular basis he was still
the most popular guy around even well
into his old age in the year 1980
personally payin her a pair of the
iconic Hollywood sign and the city of
Los Angeles gave him a star on the
celebrity Walk of Fame as a thank-you
gift in the 1980s playboy began to
struggle as a brand after it became a
publicly shared corporation they were
competing with the likes of Penthouse
magazine so that peak in popularity was
over
you have no handed control of the
company over to his daughter Christie
who became the new CEO Hefner had tried
to give normal domestic life another
chance and he got married to his second
wife Kimberly Conrad in 1989 she gave
birth to two sons Mastan and Cooper and
they got to have a fantasy childhood
growing up in the Playboy Mansion their
relationship didn't last though once
they separated in 1988 and became
officially divorced in 2010 after the
separation Hugh havent began to invite
his girlfriends to live in the house
with him and even experimented with
bisexuality he had a polyamorous
lifestyle where he had multiple
girlfriends at one time but always had a
number one girl by his side he later
admitted that it slept with roughly 11
out of the 12 monthly Playboy cover
models in 1999 one of Hugh Hefner's ex
girlfriends Carrie Lee said that living
in the Playboy Mansion was almost like a
cult because it was so easy to get
caught up in the lifestyle and the drama
with the multiple girlfriends she got so
caught up in the playboy lifestyle that
she forgot what was considered normal in
the outside world however unlike a real
cult the girls living in the house were
free to come and go as they pleased they
still had their own personal
relationships and kept in touch with
their families some of them even went to
college classes full or part-time and
their work with playboy helps them pay
for their tuition in 2005 the reality TV
series Girls Next Door premiered and it
gave people a look into the lives of the
people living and working
in the Playboy Mansion it revealed Hugh
Hefner's new lifestyle with a team of
employees to take care of all of his
needs the girls he lived with were also
given an allowance to buy whatever they
wanted of course though living in the
mansion came with the understanding that
Hugh Hefner only wanted to be involved
in an open relationship where he could
sleep with whoever he wanted but the
girls were not allowed to have another
boyfriends even though this may seem
like a dream scenario for some men the
arrangement was not always a walk in the
park for Hafner some of the women who
once lived with him sued him for
palimony after their breakup witches
like Allan and even people who are
living together but who are not married
during an interview one of Hefner's
ex-girlfriends Holly Madison explains
that women were competing with one
another for the privilege of being in
Hugh Hefner's inner circle dozens of
small-town girls would see their careers
skyrocket after modeling in Playboy and
they were desperate to become a part of
it almost every girl who was involved
with the brands moved on to either
having a big modeling career or marrying
a millionaire for some having sex with
Hugh Hefner was a very small price to
pay for guaranteed fame and fortune as
he got older you have no knew better
than to expect any of these young women
to be as true love he said during an
interview with the New York Times that
having seven girlfriends was actually a
much easier lifestyle to manage than
having just one wife in 2012 he was 86
years old and he decided that it was
finally time to settle down
he married Crystal Harris who was just
26 on the reality TV show girls next
door Hugh's girlfriends showed off their
happy lifestyles living in the Playboy
Mansion but Holly Madison came out with
a tell-all book in 2015 saying that shit
actually been manipulated into staying
with you Hafner for so many years she
said that she was truly in love with him
at first but when she finally got the
exclusive relationship that she was
looking for she was no longer in love
with him she eventually married a
millionaire event organizer called
Pascal Rotella you have no responded to
Madison's accusations in her book saying
it was an attempt to rewrite history for
the sake of staying relevant in the
media and making money on a book deal
[Music]
in 2016 it was clear that Hugh Hefner's
health was declining so he decided to
sell his mansion in Los Angeles for a
hundred million dollars to a man named
Darren metropoliz in 2018 mature Poulos
convinced the city of Los Angeles to add
protections to the house so that it can
never be torn down the Playboy Mansion
has essentially been turned into a
historical landmark you have not died
peacefully in September of 2017
surrounded by his friends and family
when he was 91 years old even though he
never got to meet Marilyn Monroe he
still credited her nudes for all of his
success this is why he purchased the
burial plot right next to hers love him
or hate him
you have to is still an icon that will
be remembered forever before he passed
away he said this about his career I've
never been in it for the money
playboy isn't a business for me it has
been from the very beginning a labor of
love and that's pretty easy to say
because if you don't love all of this
you're a fool so I really hope you
enjoyed that video if you did please do
give us a thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe we have a few videos released
every week so hit that subscribe button
hit that Bell and you will find out
about all of those give us a like if you
enjoyed it and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]